this is very interesting uh so former
got a former Pastor here so you were
actually trying to convert Muslims at
one time yes sir now you're listening to
us here listening to the beach you're
watching the D show before Oh man since
2007 or 2008 2007. yes sir yeah tell us
a little bit about that well I was doing
campus ministry at Penn State I was a
campus pastor at Penn State so that's
where I met a lot of people from other
it's International students a lot of
them are practicing Muslims so at that
point uh you know I was trying to share
my faith in Christ we always came across
trinitarian issues things like that but
I remember it was an atheist that
actually said to me years ago where I
was saying that to them that Jesus was
God at the time they said well where is
that a requirement in the Bible to
obtain salvation what if you don't
believe that Jesus is God do you go to
hell and I could not Finance in the
Bible ever since I could never get a
satisfaction answer that's always in the
back of my mind but the deity of Christ
was never a Salvation issue to begin
with but Jesus never claims to be God
anyway in actuality when you're honest
about what the scriptures have to say so
process of turning to Islam has been
quite a process it's not an overnight
thing and the key to it as a Christian
is to read the Bible not as one book but
as 66 separate books with different
Intentions by the authors and when you
see that it becomes very clear what the
truth is this is really really deep I'm
so glad you approached me I'm just given
a presentation we're doing a live Dean
show and he came off said I used to be a
pastor I used to watch the dean show and
alhamdulillah he's Muslim what advice do
you have for others a lot of times even
people in that position they have a
position they're out to pulpit and many
they're like okay they know a lot of the
stuff that's being taught preaching
taught that they don't have text there
that are in the original or any original
manuscript you don't have original
manuscripts so a lot of people end up
compromising you actually didn't do that
you actually you know went deeper you
know I'm sure you asked the Creator
alone for guidance right yes of course
so what was it what advice do you give
for other pastors other people are out
there who they know they go to Seminary
school and there's seeing Matthew didn't
write Matthew Luke didn't write Luke
they're seeing certain contradictions
but they believe in God they believe
that there has to be there that there's
an ultimate truth like you did what do
you advice do you have for him well it's
interesting to say that because it's
true the the Bible are actually an
anonymous letters that's true but that's
not what my concern was my concern is
more the Theology and so when you see
the words of Christ compared to Paul I
like to say to Christians today they
follow pollyannity not really
Christianity because what Jesus teaches
is actually a different message than
Paul Paul says that he he curses two
people by name Jesus says to forgive
people and he says on the cross father
forgive them they know not what they do
but like I said the Apostle Paul he
curses people Jesus says that not one
jot or diddle Tittle will remain will go
away from the law but the Apostle Paul
he's against the eating restrictions and
he says the one who follows the Torah is
accursed even though Psalms 19 says that
God Reveals His his life through the
Torah in all of Psalms 119 says that the
Torah the law gives you life so how can
someone who is a believing Jew Paul say
that he's against the Torah and you're
cursed for that and Jesus agrees with
the Old Testament and if you find
Muhammad you will find Jesus anyway
because Muhammad leads you to Jesus and
Jesus does give life yes but Muhammad
it's the message they point to Allah
they point to one God Jesus says worship
Allah worship God Muhammad says the same
Abraham says the same I just want to
share that just separate Paul from Jesus
and the truth to become clear that's the
one more thing and we're gonna have to
have you on to talk deeper about these
things how much easier is it now when
you're communicating to humanity the
simple message of pure monotheism
because if people can understand that
that's what Islam is about worshiping
the Creator not the creation that's
right instead of trying to you know
convince people about Trinity God being
a man you know part of God fully God
half God whatever you know how much
easier is it now I I don't know I think
it's hard because a lot of with
Christians you're dealing with in
America at least as a whole I mean just
the message conveying the message the
guidance is in the hands of God Almighty
Allah but you know just explaining this
simple message
yeah I find it easier with
non-christians actually uh it seems like
more people are accepting of one God
because it's simple and most Americans
find that simple Christians have a lot
of presuppositions you have to contend
with so you really have to take more
time with them and patience and things
like that but I always try to point to
what Jesus says go to one God what does
Abraham do go to one God and then
sometimes the Christians will bring up
race I'll say well job the oldest book
in the Torah is actually the Book of Job
not Genesis and job was a gentile not a
Jew because it's not based on race it's
based on the message so it's the message
is to worship one God you know like the
shamas Israel
God is one and so that's what Islam
teaches tauhi that God is one I feel
like I got born again when I finally
realized that God is one that's it
there's nothing where you worship except
the creator of Allah simple that's what
you have to do simple just worship on
God and be obedient do your best just do
your best to be obedient and worship on
God and give him thanks to that Faith
thank you so much thank you sir here
with former Pastor say your name again
Brad former Pastor Brad here on the dean
show look forward to having you back for
a real episode of God willing inshallah
thank you sir